I'm going to ask for three things can we
show that a particle whose motion is
gathered by this equation can we show
that it's simple public emotion secondly
it can we find it's sort of in important
statistics namely its center of motion
how frequently it moves in simple
regression how frequently it oscillates
and can we find its amplitude how far it
moves back and forth lastly can we find
where at what position is it moving at
half its maximum speed okay at what
place places this really isn't moving at
you know 50% of how fast it can possibly
go so let's start this up shall we how
do I show that it's simple thumping
motion now because this topic has so
many different equations family where do
I start
right now I've kind of given you a clue
already because of how it turns this if
I want to show that something simple
harmonic motion I've got these two
options okay if I can show you know
it'll be one or the other
okay so I need to get something to do
with acceleration and something to do
with X okay so anytime so when you think
about this one of these being my goal
okay what I've got is V squared I've got
two gets from V squared to something to
do with acceleration so we can which
equation helps us do that
yeah yeah good this is going to be the
1/2 V squared one right so I'll start
over here this is Part A I'm going to
say well look I know what X double dot
is in terms of V squared
namely it's the derivative of 1/2 V
squared okay do differ with respect to X
so therefore since I know exactly what V
squared is I just have to divide it by 2
and then differentiate right so just to
make sure I don't skip any steps divide
everything by 2 that will give me minus
x squared on to plus 7x on 2 minus 6
ok all right
differentiate minus x squared on tutor
becomes minus X 7 X 1/2 is just going to
become 7 on 2 3 and 1/2
okay so I'll differentiate it now hold
on a second what did I want to show
again I want to show simple harmonic
motion right so looking at these two
here which does it look like it's going
to be
I've got a cosmic flying over here right
so it looks to me like it's going to be
this it's not as simple
they're not just proportional to each
other okay I've been moved off a little
bit now this is not quite nothing almost
there
I've got to show it's in this form okay
so I'm going to rewrite this in a factor
I want to make it really obvious okay so
I'm going to put a minus at the front
now I want an N squared right
so that N squared will come from the
coefficient of x which in this case is
just what so even though it's a little
bit redundant but I'm going to write it
as minus 1 squared that's that's my hand
okay then I've got X and because I took
a minus sign out this changes over here
so just watch out for your signs okay
all right that's it that's the equation
I need so I can say which is in the form
but I am just quoted over there right
there for its simple harmonic motion
okay I mean getting to this kind of
point is a bit like saying you know I
get to a forum like this so therefore
you know it must be a circle okay same
idea once I get the equation in a
certain pattern that's sufficient so
there's part a